dos suburbios obreros de buenos aires-
marcaron la vida del astro argentino
diego armando maradona nació el 30 de
octubre de 1960 en una luz fue el quinto
de ocho hijos en una casa humilde y
vivió su infancia en el asentamiento
marginal de villa fiorito donde lo
despiden sus aficionados se maradona
pelusa se escapaba de los papás seguido
a jugar con gustavo éste era la alegría
de él jugar el crecer en medio de la
pobreza no fue un obstáculo para
convertirse en un prodigio del fútbol y
por el contrario inclinó su postura
política con tan sólo 15 años debutó con
los argentinos juniors en el estadio que
hoy lleva su nombre y una década después
hizo historia en el mundial de 1986 en
el que argentina fue el campeón pocos
años después de terminar la dictadura a
la que maradona crítica
pero más que trazar su carrera
futbolística el campeonato lo acercó al
que sería su gran amigo fidel castro
recibió a maradona en cuba luego de que
un medio local lo premiará como el mejor
deportista de américa latina
desde entonces forjaron una estrecha
relación maradona tenía un tatuaje en su
pierna con el rostro del líder de la
revolución cubana y otro del che guevara
eso y castró lo motivó a que se
internara en dos ocasiones en clínicas
de la habana para un tratamiento contra
su drogadicción fue un segundo padre
mi nombre
un hombre al cual yo
adoro crecer en un barrio pobre y
acercarse a fidel afianzó la pasión de
maradona por la izquierda
latinoamericana en vida apoyo a líderes
como los kirchner en argentina a evo
morales en bolivia y a hugo chávez en
venezuela siempre viajando a los países
y apoyando a sus gobiernos